[Música]
escenas de gozo en la capital de sri
lanka en las calles de Colombia cientos
de personas celebraron la dimisión del
presidente gotabaya rayapaxsa
Bueno hay un espíritu festivo en este
momento creo que la gente aquí está muy
contenta con esta decisión
una salida confirmada el viernes por la
mañana por el parlamento desde Blanca la
carta de dimisión del presidente
rayapacsa enviada por correo electrónico
tras su llegada a Singapur ha sido
validada
he recibido la dimisión del presidente
gotabaya rayapacsa de acuerdo con el
artículo 38:1 de la Constitución de la
República socialista democrática de sri
lanka En consecuencia el presidente ha
renunciado legalmente a la presidencia
el Primer Ministro Daniel buitremesingue
es ahora el presidente en funciones
según la Constitución el parlamento
tiene 30 días para nombrar a su sucesor
los diputados lo originan en los
próximos 7 días
el tiempo se acaba sri lanka atraviesa
actualmente una grave crisis económica
La Isla se enfrenta a cortes de
Electricidad escasez de combustible
escasez de alimentos y una inflación
récord para salir de la crisis una
solución desbloquear las negociaciones
con el fondo monetario internacional y
obtener un plan de rescate